you know I heckled him did you I had
Rickles bring wrinkles it was the end of
his show and he's just doing question
answering and I was just way in the back
and I wasn't gonna get to meet him and I
had to have an interaction with them
yeah so I just was in the back and as he
was talking making everybody laugh I
just went he didn't say anything another
five minutes he kept doing jokes and I
just think anyway yeah I know my name
and my buddy that was it that's all I
needed
that was enough yeah fun of me were mad
at me and [ __ ] and then afterwards Oh
psych why I just really did what yeah of
course yeah I just did that is there
anything worse than you're on stage you
know you have applause built into
something and then every time you do
that joke you like you someone's gonna
yell and and when they don't yell and
you get to it you're like oh another tie
fine if you if I don't think someone's
gonna yell but if you actually go
someone's gonna yell then it just
becomes like it someone's gonna say they
I swear to god dude somebody from the
back row the upper deck can can sense
that one wavering moment you don't have
confidence it's it it's not even visible
it's something something in your voice
they just yeah telling you step back
they all move forward you step towards
them that they sit back animalistic like
the audience senses weakness they're
ready to jump I don't know what it is
yeah just yeah it's a respect thing I
like this guy [ __ ] this they kissed
without even realizing and they just
feel like and then you become the
substitute teacher up there even if it's
a weird yet like yeah but lots happens
they'll use it to yell something like
that like nice or like they just want to
be they were German honestly yeah it's
not it's usually not a nasty heckle it's
usually not a good niche almost never
nest all that I learned I learned that
watching him Caroline it's a long time
ago I watched him some he said some
words what do you say anyway okay and I
was thinking like oh you can do that so
many times like the person was like
ordering a sundae with so many times
anybody who was talking I was so [ __ ]
defensive for the first 12 years I did
this many of them were topped is that a
hair line a girdle they were all saying
this guy sucks his careers over let's
let's beat the [ __ ] out of whenever I
was thinking so I would just anybody
talked I would just [ __ ] all over them
and the amount then afterwards you know
and I was selling my CD you know people
would come up to me and be like
I was just getting potato skin sir I was
actually just saying that you know that
happened to me and they would be really
[ __ ] offended and that I'd be
standing there like god yeah then I'd
always try to remember like all right
they're not all I didn't think it no
didn't register I remember I saw you at
Caroline's Caroline's you did it now
it's just like oh I got to try that one
time could just be a person and be like
well just okay what did you say oh you
just you said oh that happens you do ok
so you know I'm talking about you can go
back to your AG instead of you like hey
nice head you [ __ ] [ __ ] just like
even though that feels better to say